lui à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui petite pêche aliments à 3
donc en compagnie du petit rasta portion
du canal donc qui n'est peut-être pas le
canal du midi puis je suis pas tout à
fait certain devrait y avoir pas mal de
choses intéressantes c'est un coin dans
lequel on peut facilement se débarrasser
de preuves compromettantes et dans tous
les cas au pire ce serait une jolie
dépollution en droit mais ta bulle bien
c'est bon tout ça me paraît trop plat
beaucoup d'argent allez on y va
[Musique]
dans les votes
les normes et bien atteint hop voilà ta
monde
ouais sympa donc là j'ai eu quelque
chose c'est pas en entier mais
j'ai quelque chose aux
valises
[Musique]
voilà
à ses mains pas de malice 1,7 à doha
ouais ouais le gros stack off ted ya le
pc avec aaa
on regarde mais qui a remonté
way est rentré du truc le club d'athènes
pouvait l'en terrain
est possible dans une poubelle
ah bah ouais ouais asie où
c'est intéressant un genre de flop un
plateau ou un flop barbecue
la foule qui sont encore
un vin
vienne genre de pétrole
matériel devrait conduire est en fait
sinon c'est pas un sac lesté c'est juste
été emballés ouais
[ __ ] ça va atta et heavy metal
mais ces raisons
la vie et par oui
bien cuisiner un ouais
la chaleur bien ouais
à barres de fer tout faire je dédicace à
crise non aux
morceaux trouvait là clairement ouais
c'est dégueulasse allez jolie date est
plus lourd que le pneu enfin et c'est
peut-être à vannes mais
est bien mais là on l'a déjà rasé comme
il faut dans l'au delà alors tu farhi
sur quoi pronostics vélo qua non
c'est possible c'est le palmarès ouais
un peu ya longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu
aller
[Musique]
sans voiture
ou un bocal au programme de mobilité
[Musique]
les belles bêtes il est fâcheux au du
coup n'est pas entier sympa bien vrai
saas et du cloud là on parle tout droit
il ya quelque chose peut-être une
branche mais il n'y a pas forcément en
entier mais il ya une partie
non je redis tabouret mais
quoi de
ça je sais quoi voici vous savez un
commentaire wahou en aussi bonne et
assez rare ils vont acheter quoi avec
tout ça qu'est ce que je vais faire de
tout cet oreille là tu sens la mama dh
et là elle sait ce que je veux faire je
met dans la poche je vais le perdre a eu
avec presque toutes les pièces voit la
super c'est encore un gros truc
occupé par
ça bouge au ténor atteint faut juste ne
désarma s'ils gardent bien nos droits
bon
alors il ya une sacrée vase allez vas-y
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais
vélo y est compliqué non oh le joli rose
on prend pas
voyez pas de système cadré tous les
coups ne tombons
3 et 1 passe ont affiché c'est bien tu
es sage mais joli
tu vas d'étayer ou pas le chargeur usb
jack en direct puisque est marrant c'est
qu'il est neuf voix il encore ah oui là
encore emballés et même le plastique
autour de faits courriel qui achetait sa
peau au loup couteau
avait il va peut-être avec des trucs de
barbecue
shooting pong
ou alors énormes demeurent
aïe aïe aïe
encore un chargeur pur - mais oui ça
c'est un vrai hein photo 9 mm bébés
phoques ont un chargeur on trouve pas
l'argent
on a trouvé cette arme bons pronostics
et commentaires va t'en as trouvé
ça vous le saurez dans le titre et bien
écoutez je pense qu'on a fait tout pour
cette portion du canal malheureusement
on n'a pas trouvé l'armé qui allait avec
le chargeur ça sert à rien de continuer
à chercher nous on a on a bien nettoyé
cette portion là on a on a vraiment plus
grand chose ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on se décale un petit peu vers la
ville pour voir ce qu'on peut trouver
d'autres grandes villes sous un pont
donc été serein déjà fait mais au
contraire des dingueries normalement les
ponts et tour des folies donc c'est
parti pour la pêche qui avait jusqu'à
j'attire éléments on va voir ce qu'est
notre beau
et bien rien pour l'instant
ensemble de cailloux un peu
ouais
hoarau au briquet zippo sûrement
oui oui c'est bien c'est remplir agit
quelque chose
alors de pêche
aux pour le pêcheur en l'offre aux
pêcheurs cela
il est trop vieux c'est vrai beau
symbole ah ouais avril avec solaire
alors il aime bien les poissons se la
pièce un centime tiens
hall antivol
dire quel vélo pas loin
belle trouvaille bravo
qu'est-ce qu'on a deux beaux
gosses abri
à ckoi
à ya un truc dedans
c'est un mot c'est une lettre c'est une
lettre en papier est peut-être
intéressant ça
ah je sais pas
au joli plateau c'est bon ça et pape sy
va être content il adore cela pour lui
dédicace
ouais mais du coup il est pas en argent
quoi ça c'est dommage pour monsieur est
ce que vous auriez un fer à repasser
s'il vous plaît à me prêter à faire un
stage chez huawei si vous avez ça sur
vaud
ag quelque chose de gros
le fer à repasser un énorme
c'est une première joli
c'est votre jour de chance
merci de payer ouais
et un avis d'éléphant
à oui c'est une trompe c'est une trompe
ouais et là j'ai fait un petit écouteurs
sans fil
pas mal
on a déjà sorti pas mal de mer demain
avec des douilles beaucoup de douilles
[Musique]
mais
bon bah voilà donc la vidéo tous à sa
fin quand vous avez pu le voir dans
cette ville on a fait deux spots mais on
a senti énormément de ferraille des
erreurs 300 kg dans le
capital de base dans les chalets l'été
c'est pas grave c'est une très belle
pêche quand même aller à la semaine
prochaine
j'ai passé la main dans les cheveux